c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
[Musique]
je m kelly sur la plage
après je vais mettre sublime après je
vais m géraldine géraldine kim et maxime
en photo tu vois je râle et sympa elle
pose avec lui elle mais la photo et et
maxime parce que maxime il met tout le
temps des photos de coulisses de
conférences ou de régie ou truc comme ça
donc maxime kelly géraldine ça se bouge
et tout faux et ses quelques amis le qui
ce qui lui arrive
[Musique]
alors ah oui d'accord la sas et maxime
ça c'est mathieu et ça c'est jean michel
arias maxime avait trouvé
alors moi je dirais que bon bah là c'est
valérie forcément un la fin de tout ça
voilà le tissu
là je dirais maxime est assez chiant ça
lui ressemblera c'est hélas et julien
martin aime beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'économistes des visées sur instagram
voilà c'est son cheval
[Musique]